[Música]
kiev anunció la retirada de sus tropas
de la ciudad de lis y chang el que era
hasta ahora el último bastión ucraniano
en la provincia de logar rusia aseguró
estar ya en control total de esta región
del donbass
en dinamarca un tiroteo en un centro
comercial de la capital
copenhaguen deja varios muertos y
heridos según fuentes policiales las
autoridades anunciaron el arresto de un
hombre danés de 22 años presuntamente
relacionado con los hechos
en eeuu la policía de akrón ohio publicó
los vídeos del asesinato del afro
estadounidense william walker ocurrido
el pasado lunes en las imágenes se ve
como ocho agentes de policía dispararon
decenas de veces contra el hombre el
asesinato desató nuevas protestas contra
el racismo y la violencia policial en
eeuu
buenas tardes bienvenidos a las noticias
de france 24 soy rosa pérez masdéu y es
para mí un gusto acompañarles empezamos
esta edición con información relacionada
con la guerra en ucrania porque el
ejército de kiev anunció la retirada de
sus tropas de la ciudad de lis y chang
el que era hasta ahora el último bastión
ucraniano en la región de lugansk la
retirada llega tras el anuncio de moscú
de hace unas horas en que reivindico
tener ya el control total de la región
de lugansk las tropas de kiev intentaron
evitar durante días esta derrota después
de haber perdido la vecina ciudad de
severodonezk hace una semana
[Aplausos]
blandiendo banderas rusas chechenas y
soviéticas se oye a estos combatientes
decir que han entrado en y si sanz los
vídeos fueron publicados en telegram por
ramzán kadyrov el líder de chechenia y
un aliado clave de vladimir putin los
vídeos corroboran las afirmaciones
hechas por rusia el viernes
las fuerzas armadas rusas siguen
avanzando con éxito en la región de
listas aunque en los últimos tres días
se ha establecido el control sobre una
planta de procesamiento de combustible
una mina y una fábrica de gelatina el
ejército ucraniano está sufriendo
grandes pérdidas en esta región
el sábado un portavoz separatista dijo
que el isi suns que estaba completamente
rodeada mientras rusia intensifica sus
ataques contra la ciudad muchos
residentes ya habían hundió
la ciudad ya no existe ha sido
prácticamente borrada de la faz de la
tierra ya no hay ningún centro de
distribución de ayuda humanitaria ha
sido golpeado
y
hubo muchas víctimas yo fui una de ellas
estaba cubierta de escombros la gente me
ayudó a desenterrar me el domingo el
ministro ruso de defensa anunció
finalmente la liberación total de la
región de lugansk tras la toma del isi
sans la última gran ciudad que seguía
bajo control ucraniano en la región su
conquista ahora abre las posibilidades
para el ejército ruso a avanzar hacia su
bians y crematorio otras dos grandes
ciudades del donbass que moscú tiene en
el punto de mira
y precisamente para abordar la
importancia de la caída de la ciudad de
leeds y chance a manos rusas como factor
clave en el desarrollo de la guerra
hablamos previamente con martín
rodríguez osés él es internacionalista y
especialista en temas de rusia el
primero de los objetivos regionales de
esta misión especial que han establecido
los rusos en el que busca el control
total de tanto lugares como de danielle
así que ya estaría cumplida la primera
parte y todo indica que se tomaría la
región de dones en relativamente poco
tiempo para las expectativas de ucrania
y de sus aliados occidentales la toma de
hecho decisión tomó menos tiempo de lo
que se esperaba porque los rusos están
tratando de cruzar un río que separa a
ser aviones desechados y les haya tomado
su tiempo pero lo han conseguido y hoy
tiene una concentración de fuerzas muy
grande por lo que es esperable que tomen
el resto de la región en menor tiempo de
lo esperado lo que hay que ver ahora es
si ese avance va a ser este
causado por algún tipo de ataque
ucraniano como se dio y bélgorod que es
territorio ruso
y traten de hacer divergen digamos los
objetivos en el terreno lo bueno logré
continuamos en ucrania porque vadim el
yak el alcalde de la ciudad oriental
ucraniana de slogans reportó el
bombardeo más intenso registrado en la
zona desde el inicio de la guerra según
los medios locales varios ataques con
lanzacohetes dejaron al menos 6 muertos
y cerca de 15 heridos esta ciudad de
mayoría rusófona y conocida como el
corazón industrial de ucrania podría
convertirse en el próximo objetivo de la
ofensiva rusa en el donbass
[Aplausos]
y más información relacionada con la
guerra en ucrania al menos tres personas
murieron y cuatro resultaron heridas
mientras decenas de residencias fueron
destruidas por explosiones no
reivindicadas en bélgorod una ciudad
rusa ubicada a 40 kilómetros de la
provincia ucraniana de kharkiv ucrania
aseguró que investiga las causas de las
explosiones pero rusia acusa
directamente a kiev laurel tiene los
detalles la ciudad rusa de bélgorod
amaneció con el sonido de fuertes
explosiones que dañaron a 11 edificios
de apartamentos a 39 casas particulares
y que destruyó completamente a una casa
según el gobernador de la región los
residentes atestiguan de la fuerza del
impacto willis el techo se derrumbó y la
bola de fuego no me di cuenta de la bola
de fuego porque ya estaba histérica
levanté a mi hijo y nos arrastramos
justo sobre el cristal así como si
estuviéramos nadando salimos a la calle
yo me estaba levantando en ese momento y
fui lanzado hacia la puerta por la ola
explosiva los cristales de las ventanas
salieron volando mi espalda sufrió un
ligero por estas explosiones serían
producto de los desechos de tres misiles
que según moscú fueron disparados por
ucrania y derivados por los sistemas de
defensa aérea rusos
quiero enfatizar que este ataque con
misiles fue planeado y llevado a cabo
deliberadamente contra civiles en
ciudades rusas
los activos de defensa aérea rusos
destruyeron en el aire los tres misiles
balísticos que estaban equipados con
ojivas de racimo y fueron lanzados por
los nacionalistas ucranianos con tal
bélgorod
desde el inicio de la ofensiva de
músculo en ucrania rusia acusa o varias
veces a las fuerzas ucranianas de haber
efectuado ataques en territorio ruso
especialmente en esta región de bélgorod
a sólo unos kilómetros de la frontera
con ucrania
cerramos así el bloque relacionado con
la guerra en ucrania pero seguimos en
europa vamos con una noticia en
desarrollo porque en dinamarca este
domingo una persona irrumpió en un
centro comercial de la capital
copenhaguen y abrió fuego contra los
presentes de momento se cuentan varios
heridos y fallecidos según las
autoridades danesas que han confirmado
tres hospitalizaciones pero no han
avanzado más cifras eso sí la policía ya
informó del arresto de un hombre danés
de 22 años sospechoso del tiroteo
cambiamos de información vamos ahora a
eeuu este domingo la policía de akrón
ohio publicó los vídeos del asesinato
del afro estadounidense william walker
ocurrido el pasado lunes en las imágenes
se ve como ocho agentes de policía
dispararon decenas de veces contra el
hombre que había echado a correr para
escapar de un control de tráfico en el
cuerpo de walker se hallaron hasta 60
heridas de bala la indignación por el
asesinato desató nuevas protestas contra
el racismo y la violencia policial en
eeuu escuchemos la reacción de las
autoridades
no hay duda de que el vídeo que acabamos
de ver es extremadamente inquietante y
despertará muchas emociones y
sentimientos es impactante y difícil de
asimilar
no sabemos el número exacto de veces que
dispararon esto es algo que la oficina
de investigación criminal descubrirá en
su examen de evidencia sin embargo según
el vídeo anticipo que ese número será
alto se disparó muchas veces
y
continuamos en eeuu que ha pedido
25 millones de dosis más de la vacuna
bavaria nordic contra la viruela del
mono a la melé la medida llega después
de que la ms pidiera mantener la
vigilancia sobre la enfermedad a pesar
de descartar la emergencia sanitaria
actualmente se han registrado más de
5000 casos de viruela del mono en 51
países reino unido es el más afectado
con
1.235 contagios confirmados es decir en
territorio británico se cuentan más del
20 por ciento de los casos globales
veamos el informe
amenazó con arruinar el primer desfile
del orgullo en reino unido- desde el
inicio de la pandemia el sábado las
autoridades instaron a las personas con
síntomas de viruela del mono que
incluyen sarpullido fiebre y fatiga a
permanecer en casa el brote actual está
afectando de forma desproporcionada a
los hombres homosexuales y bisexuales y
queremos asegurarnos de que son
conscientes de los signos y síntomas la
preocupación por la propagación de la
viruela del mono va en aumento después
de que la oms advirtiera que los casos
en europa se han triplicado en las
últimas dos semanas el virus que se
propaga por contacto estrecho se había
limitado a zonas de áfrica occidental y
central pero actualmente hay más de 5000
casos de viruela del mono en 51 países
en los que el virus no es endémico reino
unido ha registrado más de 1200
contagios el mayor número de europa para
frenar la propagación la ms ha pedido
una acción urgente coordinada y países
como alemania y reino unido- están
haciendo precisamente eso han decidido
vacunar a personas de alto riesgo con
dosis de nordic bavarian desarrolladas
originalmente para tratar la viruela por
su parte eeuu ha pedido otros dos
millones y medio de dosis por lo que los
expertos temen que la demanda de la
vacuna supere los suministros mundiales
a medida que fomentamos el intercambio
de estos productos es realmente
importante que también recogemos los
índices de eficacia clínica para seguir
recopilando datos significado de ella
lado ms dice que el 10 por ciento de los
pacientes con viruela del mono han sido
hospitalizados o aislados una persona ha
sido ingresado en la uci mientras que el
número de muertes en los países en los
que el virus es endémico asciende a 73
los expertos aseguran que es improbable
que este virus desemboque en una
pandemia como la del cobit 19
cambiamos ahora de información vamos a
israel porque el gobierno acusó al grupo
extremista libanés hezbollah de intentar
atacar con drones una plataforma de gas
israelí situada en aguas reclamadas por
ambos países
el episodio amenaza con incrementar las
tensiones sobre la ubicación de esta
plataforma así como los esfuerzos para
acordar una frontera marítima entre
israel y líbano
estas imágenes publicadas por las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes el sábado
pretenden mostrar el momento en que tres
drones disparados por el grupo libanés
hezbollah fueron derribados dijeron que
los drones se dirigían al campo de gas
de cariz a menos de 100 kilómetros de
las costas de israel
hezbollah confirmó el incidente del
sábado sin decir que los drones habían
sido interceptados el sábado por la
tarde tres drones desarmados fueron
lanzados hacia el disputado campo de
caris para realizar misiones de
reconocimiento la misión fue cumplida y
el mensaje fue recibido líbano a israel
que comparten fronteras se han
enfrentado en los últimos años por los
recursos del mar las tensiones de
aumentar el mes pasado cuando un buque
fletado por israel operado por una
empresa griega entró en el campo de
cariz e instaló una plataforma
provocando una rápida respuesta des bola
ya lleva al hecho de que él y una niña
han talan
la empresa griega y sus propietarios
deben saber que son socios de la
agresión que se está produciendo en el
líbano en estos momentos
nuestra la instó además a las
autoridades israelíes a esperar a que
las negociaciones que cuentan con la
mediación de eeuu den sus resultados las
negociaciones se han estancado en los
últimos años mientras los dos países que
están oficialmente en guerra se disputan
las lucrativas reservas de energía
y vamos ahora con la noticia del día de
áfrica y es que los líderes de áfrica
occidental se han reunido en accra la
capital de ghana para revisar su plan de
acción frente a las juntas militares que
han tomado el poder en malí guinea y
burkina faso respecto a mali los
miembros de la comunidad económica de
áfrica occidental anunciaron el
levantamiento de sanciones después de
que las autoridades militares malienses
se comprometieron a celebrar elecciones
legislativas en octubre de 2023 y
presidenciales en febrero de 2024 por
otro lado los líderes africanos
aceptaron el compromiso de burkina faso
de reestablecer el orden constitucional
en dos años mientras rechazaron el plazo
de tres años de transición democrática
propuesto por la junta de guinea a la
que dieron hasta finales de julio para
ofrecer un nuevo plan
y cerramos esta edición con información
deportiva desde dinamarca donde culminó
este domingo la tercera etapa del tour
de francia con el ciclista de países
bajos dylan groen rieguen como vencedor
la jornada de hoy se disputó a lo largo
de un tramo de 182 kilómetros sobre
llano que inició en vélez y terminó en
son der borg de momento el belga bart
continúa vistiendo el maillot amarillo
muchísimas gracias por su atención
sigan con nosotros
[Música]